on vient à montréal
autre manifestation les compte plus en
fait des chauffeurs de taxis contre
hubert des chauffeurs il faut le dire à
qui la ville impose de nouvelles règles
et françois cormier le maire colère
présenté aujourd'hui les détails de ces
règles oui alors qu'un peu partout dans
le monde finalement des chauffeurs de
taxi manifestaient contre les services
hubert effectivement l'administration
coderre préciser certaines règles
qu'elle imposera à partir du 1er janvier
2016 patrice à commencer par le code
vestimentaire donc à partir du 1er
janvier il sera obligatoire pour les
chauffeurs de taxi de porter le pantalon
noir ou la jupe noire si les femmes le
désire également la chemise la blouse ou
le chandail style polo si vous voulez
blanc donc ça ce sera obligatoire pour
les impôts pour les hommes et pour les
femmes et en été on pourra porter le
bermuda noir nous dit-on également les
chaussures fermées ainsi que les
chaussettes à l'intérieur des chaussures
seront obligatoires également à partir
du 1er janvier mais là ils auront un an
pour se conformer les caméras de
surveillance qui seront obligatoires
dans chacun des véhicules
à montréal des véhicules taxis qui
vendent finances et c'est exactement ce
n'est pas clair patrice la ville dit
qu'il va essayer de trouver des fonds
nécessaires mais n'exclut pas que les
propriétaires de taxis est leur part à
faire on écoute là tu le mets reconnaît
dans certains cas notamment au niveau
des caméras gardons en train de
finaliser la question du fondre mais
c'est sûr que ça va être la sphère de
tous et puis on se donne un encadrement
c'est vrai aussi avec les intermédiaires
les nouveaux propriétaires et son nom
s'est donné un premier cadre
réglementaire qui permet justement
c'est un corps les bottines suivent les
babines ya pas de bo taxi n'est pas la
france y en a pas ottawa n'a pas honte à
guesnain pas les bras c'est moyen pour
vous de votre fête ses 5 ans et pour les
autres d'accord mais bien sûr une bonne
idée d'avoir des caméras de surveillance
dans tous les textes pas du tout prêt du
tout parce que si quelqu'un est
schizophrène il faut faire quelque chose
là c'est après votre mort on va discuter
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé à je suis
partout mais où il travaille
c'est ça je peux porter des chemises le
port des vêtements je reste assis toute
la journée
c'est quoi ça depuis 8h jusqu'à
maintenant je vis une course 14 dollars
et il faut dire que le paiement
obligatoire c'est-à-dire qu'il puisse
nous offrir de payer électroniquement
c'est octobre ça c'est bientôt dès le 15
octobre effectivement radio bon vous
nous parlez de baseball parce que
vendredi à rien n'annonce pas de
nouveaux clubs q qu'est ce que le mais
ce que le maire coderre a dit ce matin c
il y aura une annonce vendredi par
rapport au baseball c'est tout pas plus
de mocassins
il n'en fallait pas plus pour enflammer
les réseaux sociaux patrice vous auriez
dû voir tous les retweet les questions
les réactions les gens qui pensaient
qu'ils avaient peut-être une annonce
concernant un club qui sans viendra
montréal un nouveau stade
calmons nous tout le monde sauf que si
c'est ça la nouvelle ce sera une
surprise pour tout le monde
ce qu'on entend dans les corridors c'est
probablement qui aura des matchs hors
syrie qui seront présentés au stade
olympique a au printemps et que
l'annoncé serait faite donc vendredi
bref on verra l'a fait la semaine ils
voulaient plus le maire eelv lmh la
saison régulière on verra c'est ça des
matchs hors saison en saison régulière
françois merci au bob à deux